alan dershowitz is of course a professor
emeritus at harvard law school he's the
author of the case against impeaching
Trump and he joins us tonight professor
from what you have seen of this FISA
application what's your response
well I think Congress ought to ask the
people who drafted the FISA response why
they deliberately left out the fact that
the Clinton campaign and the Democratic
National Committee paid for the steal
dossier that's question number one
question number two why did they if they
did we don't know about the redactions
why did they leave out the fact that the
dossier also had the salacious
allegations about urination and beds the
kind of thing that would make any judge
look very suspiciously on the source of
the material instead what they did is
they said this is a guy who had
previously given them reliable
information without indicating that now
it looks like he may be giving them very
partisan and very unreliable information
so I think we need to get the answers to
those questions before we can come to
any firm conclusion I'm struck by the
treatment that Carter page has received
in the press here's a guy who's not been
charged with any crime there's no
credible evidence he betrayed his
country he's been accused of treason by
his own government and spied upon and
yet the reservoir of sympathy for him
seems very shallow no one seems to care
why is that because in our partisan
world the presumption of innocence only
applies to your side not the other side
Democrats and people on the Left forget
the presumption of innocence they're
prepared to argue that a search warrant
is proof of guilt or an indictment as
proof of guilt for example the
indictment of the 12 Russians who will
never be brought to trial is taken as
containing the truth they're just
allegations it may very well be that
they're guilty and we know there was
intrusion or an attempt to intrude on
the election but we have to remember the
presumption of innocence it doesn't only
apply to your side of the political
spectrum that's exactly right
you really are the last liberal in
America and I'm glad that you're here so
recently the creepy porn lawyer the guy
who's representing stormy Daniels said
he knows about the contents
taped conversations between Donald Trump
and his lawyer Michael Cohen you pointed
out the obvious if he knows what's
inside then he's able to obtain sealed
information and that's bad here's how
you described it I do know there's more
tapes of President Trump there's
multiple tapes of President Trump number
one how do you know there are other
tapes involving the President of the
United States are you privy to what was
seized from the office that's that's a
very important question I wish you'd
answer it well I'm not gonna answer your
question because I don't have to answer
your question if we're right then you
have access to information that's
supposed to be sealed and supposed to be
secret how do you have that information
well you know I've answered advice yeah
go ahead yeah I mean do you think he has
the information well he that or is
making it up look he also accused me to
deflect from my very hard question he
accused me of making false predictions
whereas all of his predictions are
correct
his major prediction in May was that
President Trump would resign
we're waiting to see that happen I
predicted accurately what the Supreme
Court would decide in the travel ban
case I predicted accurately who
president Trump would nominate to the
Supreme Court all of my predictions have
come true and almost none of the
naughties predictions have come true
also the American Bar Association had an
article recently about the ethical
concerns that lawyers an ethics expert
like professor Stephen gillers of NYU
have about a vanadis
conduct so I think basically his conduct
speaks for itself and my predictions
look you know I wrote a book you
mentioned it before the case against
impeaching Trump in my book the
predictions are all in there anybody can
read them anybody can see that I've been
straight on I've been accurate the
reason I'm accurate is because I don't
have a partisan dog in this fight I just
call them as I see them and sometimes my
predictions help one side or help the
other but I'm not trying to make
self-fulfilling prophecies the way
avenatti and others on the extreme side
of this are making self predicting
self-fulfilling prophecies let's wait to
see a president Trump resigns and if he
doesn't put avenatti on the show
confront him with that prediction he not
only made a prediction he said I
guarantee you guarantee you that
President Trump will resign after
hearing what Rudy Giuliani said and what
avenatti said it's total nonsense we've
invited him many times so far this is
the only show he won't do well have him
on fire thank you for everyone with me
good anytime I would love that thank you
very much